oh boy look who just joined the show
ladies and gentlemen Dell Rawlings is
here I'm rich [__] hello I just feel
like that's my intro if people don't
know the name right they know the iconic
uh phrase that's got me in so much
trouble with my friends well it's
annoying when people keep yelling your
stuff out though right you embrace it I
guess no no I got a huge ego and I'm
vain and I want them to recognize me
from something I don't have a problem
with it at all oh you like it okay you
don't mind it in fact I you know um I've
been an ashy dude my entire life and
when we were doing Chappelle Show when
he asked me what am I going to do to
prepare for this role I said just take a
shower and wait 15 minutes and I and
you're ready and ashle L meod actor yeah
I'll be a method actor y okay so you're
hosting for sway today is is he like out
for a while or just for today I think
it's a day but it's something to say
about that man because every time um I
think that he looks at who's going to be
guest on the show and then that's when
he like decides go on vacation every
time I come and say when are you going
to be on the show oh you want a co-host
so I think that's situation I really
don't think sway likes me anymore oh so
he just when you're here he decides not
yeah he's like does Donell can cover for
me I don't I don't I don't understand
why I thought we had a good friendship
but I don't even I don't even know if
sway is alive I haven't seen pictures of
him in so long but if he lets you
co-host that's a good sign not co-host
he's not in there right well I mean if
he gives you his show for a day that's I
don't know I think Dell's on did
something he's like you do the interview
by yourself I'm not showing yeah there
you go and I'm working out I need a job
man but you have a break now how do you
have a break though if you're live on
that show because with a lot of times
with um Urban radio they have what they
call a like a Friday mix or like a mix
where a popular DJ and I'm know sounds
like feels like I'm introducing you to
something that you didn't know oh you
certainly are all right so like this is
lot with urban urban radio they have
like a a mix Friday mix the throwback
mix whatever where a popular DJ goes in
and he does like a freestyle DJ session
of half hour which allowed me 30 minutes
to come here and get reconnected with
with a person I consider to be a friend
from back in the day in that's you thank
you sir that's so nice who's the DJ DJ
wonder I don't know DJ DJ W is a regular
guy over there he's a he's excellent yes
he's excellent Caucasian DJ not that
that you have to be a certain race to be
a good DJ but he's very funny I mean
he's very good and he's very popular in
the streets the streets the streets love
him the streets like white DJs typically
or no yeah the streets like white DJs
that got swag to them but white DJs are
I think they probably uh make the most
money out of all the DJs with that o oof
I don't know what type of music the you
know what EDM electronic music yeah I
mean you got like DJs EDM DJs that are
making like millions and millions of
dollars they're making stoki is he an
EDM dj or no yep and they're making just
as much as like any traveling band
exactly like they're they're not they're
making as much if not more than the
musicians that they're playing and then
with technology now is not like in the
old days when you were a DJ you still
had to employ two or three other people
to carry your crates right I mean with
technology dudes are just walking in
with their laptop and just pluging it
into the setup and then you got Pooky
the crackhead like yo you stole my job
with that laop but you know just move
Evolution Evolution that's what they
said it's so it's so easy now that those
electronic DJs like the key I watched
Steve aoki's documentary or whatever on
Netflix and the key is that they'll book
like three or four gigs in a day right
and they'll have a private plane that
will just take them from gig to Gig to
Gig to Gig because there's no setup time
there's no sound check there's no
anything they just show an introduction
you just introduced yourself and then
you're right there plug their [__] in do
the hour and a half get on a plane do
the next gig yeah it's amazing they
talking about how they do it New Year's
Eve yeah we had the Phantoms in and uh
they just do gig what do they call it
chasing there's a term for what they
they go from gig to Gig to Gig like as
the clock they cross the country right
yeah just looking at the time zones yeah
it's it's amazing how much money you can
make doing that [__] mean my dumb
[__]
act God I wish had some musical ability
I want to go buy some turntables right
right now man let's switch the game up
bro I but you don't even need them
anymore like he just plug he plays it
and then it just I think the hard part
is to keep look busy looking up there CU
otherwise people like what the [__] do
we even need you for and you know what
that's a good point because I know I'm
sure they have an app that could blend
any music together but like you say I
guess the key to a DJ is taking your
headphones and putting your putting your
ear close to your shoulder and not
looking at the audience and somebody try
to tap you're like yo yo you see what
I'm doing over here I'm busy at the same
time you just push and play like okay DJ
set number one cuz you could do it from
home you could create the whole set and
then just go and play it that's all it's
not difficult to do at all yeah I'm
quite sure that some of them guys do
that it's almost like lip syncing for
like DJs yeah there's videos of like
there's all these videos of people
catching these like huge DJs they're
getting paid millions of dollars and
they have their like hands up in the air
and everything or they're hitting
buttons and then their equipment's not
plugged in you could see it from the
back and it's just because like the
mixers aren't plugged in or something so
it's just literally they've they've
figured out they set they're just moving
and doing that's like somebody doing
like a like a man on the street um video
you ever see that man on the street
video where you know the sound is coming
from the camera but a person still has a
microphone with no cord on it like what
the hell are you doing man I'm smarter
than this [__] trying look professional
that's the funny part to me of the DJ
thing is that somebody caught it with a
camera like somebody saw that [__]
[__] thing isn't plugged in and then
took a picture and made a thing out of
it and that person is probably a troll
on the internet yeah that's the same
person that you do a show and you have
all these comments all these comments
Jim Rock Jim is a legend blah blah blah
blah and then that one person like well
I expected more from him you know like
that one [__] troll people that find
out information like that I know but
they're usually the ones who are
right you take their word usually he was
right I did mail it in God damn it I
stink and he knows I stink does that
stuff affect you or you don't give a
[__] what uh the internet stuff no I it
I I try not to say it affects me but it
affects Tex me yeah you know what I'm
saying I try to be like the tough person
I don't give a [__] when nobody thinks
about me but you get caught up in it
because you will go through a thread and
you're like oh I'm the [__] I'm the [__]
I'm the [__] I'm the [__] right you're
getting all this positive energy and
then you get one person and for some
reason you like [__] all the nice things
that I heard I want to focus on that
person same thing when you on stage you
could be ripping the audience to shreds
you know you got you're in the room 500
people and one person is not satisfied
and you'll switch your whole tone just
to try to get this one dude to follow
the $499 I don't know I don't know
whether that's about us maybe that was
what make us good I don't know what it
is but yeah I'm guilty of that I get
pissed and I respond too we feel like
that person is actually correct and the
other $499 are wrong we have to convince
him yeah it's it's almost like that's
the part of me that knows I stink and
I'm terrible it's like oh that guy gets
it and then like I've had I've had
Twitter Wars I haven't even went through
the profile or anything it'll be like a
Marky Mark 62 or something I'll be like
[__] you [__] you [__] you f [__] you
you don't know me ask my real fans right
and then I'll click on his page and he's
got like one follower yeah just [__] and
I'm like and it's probably like 13 or 14
but you know but then I think some of it
is like you don't know who that person
is so you're just responding to their
words because their words are on your
timeline it gets it's get it gets
confusing man yeah well what do you what
do you dislike more when they're
criticizing your comedy or like when you
made TMZ like a year ago or so and you
got into that fight yeah like what was
the TMZ fight well he was in a fight of
like somebody was uh saying that he
wasn't paying and he was like I'm paying
and there was like a like you were
throwing punches yeah yeah I threw none
of them landed but it looked good and
slow motion it look so good in slow
motion and it was so did you fall down
in the background now I know you're
going to get that that I sawet in the
air that's a nice way of saying did you
get knocked the [__] out you know like
we said D you were Airborne for how long
were you in the air no I didn't but I
will say it was perfect the guy swung
I'm I I ducked a punch but then I backed
into something right but it was almost
like an actor's punch you know how you
hit it on the side it looked like it was
like you know those World Star videos
like it looked and I think somebody
posted put a sound effect it was like
the guy swing did you hear like the
world sawar like oh [__] he got knocked
the [__] out I didn't I got tripped and
what happened was I was coming from a
show that night and I stopped at this
Diner and um I had uh pancakes and
something else ordered some food and I
went outside to um go have a cigarette
right and the and the lady who was
working the I don't know if she security
or host whatever she thought that I was
trying to walk out on my on my on my
check and I told her my bag was on the
inside I had my bag on the inside I
don't have no reason you know to walk
out on the check especially like a $10
check and I'm not then then she pulled
that in the in the vestival we were she
was like I don't give a [__] who he is
anytime you know this business anytime
someone says I don't give a [__] who he
is they really give a [__] who he is
they made that statement so and it
wasn't it was a it was another a patron
coming in the restaurant that came in
the middle and he he pushed me why' he
push you um um this was when um this
when uh uh the make America great
movement would was at its height yes you
know what I'm saying I was in um
Pennsylvania you know what I'm saying
I'm not saying this is the case but I
did feel like I just feel like I was in
a climate that it was like you know lock
him I mean they were saying that racial
implications yeah and I don't I don't
use the race card a lot I do use it you
know I think in um 2009 I was really
abusive with the race card like
everywhere I went I could go and
McDonald's can I get large f catch up
sir we're all out of catchup oh I see
what's going on here and that's and
that's when you know the race guard is
coming when you hear that opening l oh I
see what's going on here you don't have
no catchup cuz I'm black no sir it's
because the truck is [__] late you
know why'd you fall into that in 2009 um
because um uh it was at the height of
the Barack Obama gotcha Phenom and then
the backlash was coming yeah I got when
barck got elected man they sent me like
three different companies sent me raise
cards they they like use it man the
interest is going to go up in 8 years
but you better use it now but um so the
guy pushed you yeah he pushed me and
then I just started swinging and then
one of the guys that worked um in a
restaurant a big dude I was like I don't
think I want it with him and that's when
he swung on me the big guy yeah the big
guy he missed um and he missed and I
fell over a long story short and I did
have some drinks that night people like
this where you where you were you um
were you drinking I was like I wasn't
driving what the [__] does I have to do
anything you know but um the next day um
I woke up and I checked my email and
then I get an email from TMZ they're
like they're like they're like uh TMZ is
like um yeah we got videotape of you get
in the fight I was and I was like this
cuz I'm still recovering like who got in
the fight last night right but they were
courteous enough to see and I didn't
have a i a give a [__] about them
running story it's what happened but I
made a music video you know they say
sometimes in the worst situation that's
when your art becom stronger and I and I
did a a parody video called um it was to
Drake song um um what was that um um
Bell Rings what was that song hotline
bling hotline bling I did a video called
food B food bell rings and it was
basically like you know how they had a
ding ding ding in the diner and it was
like I don't know when the food B it
could mean on one thing every since that
day in Philly you and it talks about the
incident so I I I took a negative made
something positive about it so how did
you get out of the D I mean you know if
you were drunk you didn't remember but
how did you how did you get I wasn't
drunk Jim okay cuz you said the next day
woke up
you pain this way I wasn't drunk but why
you say drunk I was nice all right nice
yeah I was good I was good I was good so
then how did you get your bag out and
leave like those little things like did
you have to walk in and get it or they
get your Stu no I'm going be quite
honest like it was I felt like the whole
restaurant was against me but it was one
dude in there that I'm assuming that he
was a fan of mine this is a part of the
story nobody know he actually because
the lady was like he's not getting his
bag until the police come right but they
were he went in the store gave the lady
like a 30 they gave the lady like a $30
tip to get my bag oh wow okay so they
was everybody was everybody was in on
the situation so the cops never had a
problem with you no they never came just
an argument okay yeah you start talking
cops Brothers like yeah we going to talk
you get sober quick and [__] yeah we
could talk about this at another date
you know cops [__] amazing how TMZ
gets things so quickly like that's the
difference between now and years ago if
you're drunk you wake but you wake up
the next morning and it's it's been
taped yeah and the thing about it was
and I'm saying to myself cuz I never saw
the person with the camera right you
know but I'm like if I was ever St you
know I needed some cash I could go out
and set up my own TMZ situations I can
get one of my boys we do a fake fight
you know what I'm saying you videotape
it and then you go whatever a great idea
and then we go by Nikes that's a great
idea we go bu Nikes and rims and [__]
like that man you know positive [__] man
I felt bad for Chad Coleman you know
Chad Coleman from uh he was on the wies
with The Walking Dead and he's a big
character on The Walking Dead and he was
on a train in the city and he was drunk
and you could tell you're drunk he's a
really nice guy but he made this kind of
embarrassing video uh losing his [__] uh
walking up and down and uh oh it got a
lot of views but that's just the what
happens the next day you wake up and
you're like oh that's the thing is like
especially in our business like you're
excited about social media you think you
know it's a tool or whatever but now and
especially with live it's like we we're
we're we're we're living in an age where
your life is television show for someone
at any time they want yeah nobody's
saying you got to sign it's release
basically you just pull a camera out
it's like I'm going live you know so
it's kind of tough man because what are
you going to do it's on Facebook live
already we're live what are you going to
complain that you didn't sign a release
okay it's done and then like even with
stand up you know it's like you know
like I want people to say I enjoy Donell
show but now it's coming to a point
where like people trying to watch your
show and they got a camera in your face
like half you know you and then if you
curse the camera out then that's the
last edit they're going to do like get
the [__] camera on face look at Don
Rollins he has a meltdown he's going
crazy and I think all Comics at some
point going to have some type of mental
M meltdown yeah I mean it's it's a it's
cuz your material once it's out there
you're like you know you don't want it
to you can't do it again if people have
already seen it right you know that's
what that's why Comics care I don't give
a [__] because I I'm not going to
attract the attention of Ro Chris Rock
is or a Chappelle but those guys hate it
when someone pulls a camera out well
they I know Chappelle i i i tour with
him now he has that company um vonder
where they take your phones they put put
in a secure bag like when you come to
the show they you you put your phone in
this pouch and it's like a magnetic
device that locks it up you can take
your phone in but it's inside the bag
and if you he hates that cell phone
stuff yeah he does wait if you put the
they give the Bal it's a sleeve yeah
it's a sleeve like um it's Dave does it
like AIA AIA a he does it but and I mean
it's it's weird because you're watching
an audience it's like they're captivated
but it's same time in their face you can
see them looking like [__] I just want
to text I want to I want to I need to do
something now but it's protecting it's
protecting the Integrity of live
performance and it's also with with him
it's one of those things where they're
going to start yelling out show things
and filming it and you know I I don't
blame him but so what how does this
thing work they put how get it out of
the sleeve it's like it's the same um
technology as um you know how you go to
the store and they do theft prevention
magnetic situations so basically it's a
it's a it's a bag
that you can't cut I mean you can't like
easily rip it a razor blade or a knife
or something but you just put your phone
in the um in the sleeve and then it
closes right it closes and the only way
you can get out you have to put it on a
magnetic block on the way out or if you
want to go take a break or anything like
that fondor I mean Google it but it's
but you can cut through it with scissors
or something if you really want to yeah
I mean that we've seen situations where
people like like bite their [__] open
you know what I mean like and I don't
think it was to record the show it's
like some people just can can't stay
away from social social media that's
true yeah even in the movies like I was
watching the um I went to see the Star
Wars movie and in the previews a guy was
texting and I was like if he's doing
this when the film starts I'm going to
say something because I was so annoyed
this cocksuck but when the film start he
put it away but the the the selfishness
of people it's like how do you not know
that's bothering people around you
shitty people because it's so I think
it's because so many people are doing it
that you just think it's just normal so
so vonder they're called now he has to
pay them or do they do it for the advert
I'm quite sure it's a service that I'm
sure he pays it V you might want to on a
tag where it's vonder uh you got to hit
something that's going to get it close
cuz I may not if you just Google uh cell
phone sleeve you know you probably if
you just describe what it is it might be
Yonder Travis was able to find it is
that because you didn't just keep typing
the same word in over and over but I
know I knew about this a couple years
ago when when Chappelle started using it
yeah yeah but like if you like like Dell
said like if you want to go outside like
the the the GPS field like like they'll
they'll put you you know you know like a
force field around the a force field
well yeah for for lack for lack of a
better word they'll never get you got
excited about it I didn't know a for you
know you can you can go out and and your
bag will unlock and you can use your
phone while you're in the bathroom but
then once you go back into into the no
it it'll just it'll automatically lock
so you can just take your phone out in
the bathroom and then let the bag lock
itself you could but I'm sure that the
that the ushers are checking when you
when you go back to your seat yeah but
if they try to shoot you they can't get
through the force field that is true so
that is there a magnetic field oh that's
great we're all dying because of these
bags if not are ready for the cell
phones yeah and Wii is everywhere anyway
genius though man there's always a way
somebody always figures something out to
get something done yeah because you
can't block the internet like people
well just block it so no one can see but
then people will just look at stuff on
their phones or they'll tape or whatever
they'll do so when you were when when
when I'm rich [__] was at its peak cuz
you said you got in trouble with your
friends from it was everybody was
everybody assuming that you were much
more Rich than you actually were that's
the point I I wanted to make like we go
to we go to dinner like I would be my
friends and then a check could come
right and nobody would go for their
wallet they would just look like I
thought you was rich [__] I'm like
that's TV [__] no but and I was
dating this chick once and she was
really loaded and I was she had the
funniest line cuz everyone when it was
at height everybody was saying it and I
was walking down the street one day and
um somebody yelled out I'm rich [__]
and she said me too you know so
goddess she was a she was a trust fun
baby oh she her family had money her
family had lot Mone how you blow that I
didn't really blow it I just didn't um I
didn't need her for money that's still I
like to dat and she's a doctor now oh
yeah she was a doctor I've never dated a
girl with a lot of money that'd be nice
yeah and the thing about it it was like
we were we had great relationships great
relationship but she was on her way to
um to Met School I was a a road comic
she was on the west coast I was on the
east coast and it was just like it just
realistically it it wasn't going to work
yeah and it's hard on the road too
because I mean I'm a pig in New York but
on the road oh it could be hardil yeah
especially you're doing Arenas with
Chappelle it's got to be hard because
once you're done when especially when
you're the when you're the support act
you know and Dave is on you have no
pressure on you you give a [__] about
the ticket account like none of it
matter matters to you you're just going
to go up you're going to kill in front
of them because they all know you and
it's and it's so awesome for me because
of he doesn't need my name to promote
his shows so nobody knows I'm there so
it's like the DJ uh the DJ int cuz in
with in a black comic show you have to
have a DJ you do right yeah it's an
extra guy it's like a must Jewish people
like we can cut this off
20% I'll use my iPod but they they'll do
some credits like you seen them on GE
code you seen them on the wire and
people I'll get you know it'll be a
couple claps and then it's like but you
fell in love with him as as she from
Chapelle and then the place goes ape
[__] they know which forces I always
want to do well yeah but it really like
it's like it really forces you to want
to um meet them at the level of energy
that they have but they all know you
from the show which is great yeah it's
good time it's always a good time and
then you know for support act I headline
you know I'm headlin in the Carolines
this weekend but you know it's certain
names
I open for for D but for a headliner to
scale it down to like a feature 20 or 25
minute set that's like fire you know
what you can do you know you got to pay
yourself you're do an hour but you know
when you what you could do in 20 in in
20 minutes you know it's like just you
could chop the setup parts of the bits
that are kind of like all right with
this yeah it's [__] awesome trim the
fat off like bam bam bam thank you and
and it's over and then you try to get
laid that's the best part of it you just
[__] walk around backstage you creep
out into the audience you you're so
awful man I remember those days yeah I
remember those days where like it's like
you go to a bar after the show and then
you'll see a chick you be like this did
you see the show they was like no I
didn't see you like okay I'll talk to
you later yeah I have no shot of my own
merits no you need you need that help
like oh my God you were so [__] funny
and then that's when the Sinister voice
is
like I can [__] her in the bathroom yeah
yeah you know Jim wants like he keeps
hinting cuz you're a dad now you got the
whole thing going on yeah I'm I'm a new
dad I'm an old dude with a new baby
that's what I tell people right and I
know I know that to be truth because all
of my friends kids are so much older
than my son and I realized when I was um
planning my son's first birthday party I
called with my friends I'm like you
think your son can come to my son's
party and he was like if he can get off
of
work he's like yeah my son got two jobs
[__] what was he waiting for but
it's new it's new for me how old is he
now a year and a half yeah do you still
call him the N word my little [__] yeah
yeah all all day all day that's my
little [__] yeah for you with the ga
with the ga I don't do the ER with him
but yeah that's my little is he your
first kid yeah my first oh yeah that's
encouraging when I see friends in my I'm
48 so guys in my age group doing it see
okay Jim keeps hinting like while we're
doing the show cuz I've known Jim for a
long time time too and he's been hinting
way more now than ever before about
wanting a relationship right and wanting
to enter into that world but I don't
know I just don't know if he's equipped
for it yeah he's doing it we all think
about relationship when we get to the
point like I'm getting older I'm not
going to know uh uh keep track of my
pill count
yeah I need somebody to mash my
vegetables up you know what I'm saying
like basically I'm getting old I need
[__] help right now man my pill
counts easy it's half a Calis it's not
hard and that's when you really think
about relationship the first time your
member doesn't work when you need it to
you're like yeah I think it's time to
slow down but it's like it's I mean me
being a it's the dopest thing it's it's
just great and I've heard people talk
about it before all my friends I've
heard people say yo man having a baby is
the greatest feeling you ever going to
have nothing tops it I'm like I don't
know if you've ever had a a a a a
biracial Minaj oh no wow yeah but I'm
like you my son is my favorite but he
didn't win by
Landslide he definitely didn't get the
popular voice he got the electorial
college vote I was like okay it was like
it was like black chick white chick same
time black chick white chick same time
and Austin it was like I like let me see
the video tap yeah you got to go to the
kid it's dope it's dope I'm really
enjoying had a kid yeah he did Bill Bill
ber just had a a baby and Bill's our age
group so he just had a daughter real
like two a week ago oh that's awesome I
know you had your time as a dirt bag
though oh yeah yeah the old downhill oh
yeah yeah what was that what what was a
Minaj Tua multi-racial Minaj Tua like it
was um a black chick and a white chick
yeah yeah how suck your dick together um
that might be a little too graphic okay
how about this I just let you use your
imagination it was a Min and I don't
know what you do in your Min T know I
usually don't have them I usually don't
have them it was a once in a lifetime
situation me and two girls one of the
girls will suck both our
dicks I was about to say when Jim has a
Minaj [__] it's one person with both
parts
he's like killed two bears with one
stone yeah exactly I've only had a
couple of those in my life I've I have
not had a lot of threesim in my life no
I haven't either that's not you know
it's nothing to play with but it was um
it was a great time yeah it's fun oh
it's not something that you want to do
regularly yeah I don't know how we I did
the segue from how much I love my kid
banging two chicks at one time yeah life
Rockstar life yeah because you were like
yeah you started talking about the kid
and both Jim and I were both like let's
get back to the Min let's get back to
let's forget you little baby let's get
back to the real [__] I didn't know Bill
and n the baby that's awesome yeah they
did they just had uh a daughter all
happy but that makes me again I see my
friends in my age group I'm like okay
it's I'm not finished yet close but I'm
not finished do you think you're going
to have a kid though I don't know I'm
I'm not you're not ruling it out no I
don't rule it out I'm not like I got to
have when I want a baby I'm just like
yeah maybe yeah I tell that's how to be
quite honest that's how it was for me it
wasn't like cuz if you if you're
consumed with that it'll drive you crazy
yeah and I'm not you know and I wasn't
at the point I wasn't I was like you
know I'm happy with my career you know I
got nephews and all that stuff was good
you know but then when the situation
happened I was excited about it was it
wasn't like I got to have one this year
or anything but I embrac it this great
yeah the fact that you're saying maybe I
might I'm not ruling it out you're going
to attract more more 20-year-old 25y old
women for sure even 30-year old women
well if you're if you're I feel bad for
women like in their 30s cuz then your F
your box starts twitching and you're
like oh no is that how it medically work
oh yeah you got to go young if you're
going to pop one you going to have to go
young yeah I don't want woman who you
got to balance that out
I mean you my situation like my my my my
my lady is um you a lot younger than I
am I'll be dead before
both yeah and it's like this like and
and she's uh she's uh Black and Latino
so it's so easy to get her pregnant yeah
it's so easy I could cough she be like
oh my God y look we're pregnant you you
should have heard the things that were
coming out of my wife's mouth cuz it
took us well she's pregnant now
congratulations thanks man but it took
us I mean all told it was two were three
years you know just working on it
working on it working on it but it felt
like especially after it got to be a
certain amount of time our first the
dopest [__] ever but we'd be walking
around and everywhere we went she'd see
Puerto Rican girls that were pregnant
she's like godamn they are the superior
race it takes of nothing I keep trying
it could be an argument and [__] yo
poppy yo I'm pregnant yeah but that
congratulations man it's the delivery
room just remember two things just have
a lot of ice chips and lie about
everything ice chips and lies ice you're
beautiful you're beautiful yeah I lied
about everything what did you lie about
I told her I told her I told Stephanie I
said you know once we get through this
I'mma buy you some brand new
titties I told no no I whispered it cuz
her mother was here right I was like yo
I'm telling you I'm going to get you
some brand new titties and the reason
why I offer her the brand new titties
cuz she has a small chest she has a
small chest and you know it's small when
I describe it as a chess you know she
she was a 320 before she got
and she's talking about I'm thinking
about bref I'm like no the [__] you not
you better get some simac some infam
you're not going to start my baby with
the [__] EOP ass ni and
[__] I lied like [__] I'm evil man I was
in there making memes and [__] cuz she
thought it was going to be easy right
she's sitting over there like she's
eating and looking at TV she and I and I
took a picture of her in the meme said
that that face you um have before them
contractions hit right and she's looking
all happy right and then next one she
had a contraction was like and I was
like the face you make with [__] just
got real right and her mother's in the
deliv room so I'm making memes send them
to her mom and her mother's over there
laughing we had a good it was dope man
that's like how I started 2016 how I
ended 2016 how far along is your um wife
we're do like I mean we're weeks away at
any point she could she could go you
want bring Nick while Dell Dell's about
to he's going to have to leave are you
doing you damn that sound is so
aggressive like get the [__] out of here
get the [__] out time is up they just
told me that you got to go back and do
cuz sway got you working yeah s got me
work but Jim it was good man I love you
you know I love you too pleasure always
Carolines this weekend yes it's Donell
Rawlings on Twitter do n n l l n l r a
WL i n gs Dell rings.com and uh go to uh
to Caroline Dell is hilarious I still
remember um um um rip Anthony Mason but
I remember years ago air Carolines I
think that was the first time we
connected I mean we were we we both had
like no Grays or anything like that and
he was like yo man cuz Anthony Mason
thought he was funny and I destroyed him
and he was so happy he was like yo man I
love the way you killed Mason I never
forget that that was so great and even
when he passed away I like I know was
unfortunate but I thought about you I
was like damn that that's what was the
connection but thanks for having me on
your show he was the sixth man in the
NBA that year and you said you're the
Sixth Man [__] not the fifth and
it destroyed it destroyed [__] almost 20
years ago man good see you I want take a
break